المشاهدين التقدم في البرنامج الايراني
النوويه
يخرج الغرب
ويضع الدول الموقعه على الاتفاق النووي
امام اختبار صعب الحديث هنا لصحيفه لموند
الفرنسيه التي قالت ان كل من فرنسا
والمانيا وبريطانيا من جهه والولايات
المتحده من جانب اخر تواجه مازقا كبيرا
ازاء تطور البرنامج النووي لسهران فمنذ
الوقف الكامل لمحاولات احياء الاتفاق
النووي في سبتمبر الماضي تبدو هذه الدول
بحسب لمود امام معضلتين اما الاعتراف
العلني بنهايه الاتفاق والدخول في المجهول
او ارتفاع خطر التصعيد بين عقوبات
اقتصاديه جديده مشدده على ايران او حدوثه
عمليات عسكريه محتمله وخلال التعليق
المتواصل للمباحثات والمستمر منذ شهور
ساعدت ايران من الانتهاكات المتعدده
الالتزاماتها بموجب الاتفاق النووي وفق
الصحيفه رمود نقلت عن رفاي المدير لعمل
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قوله انه
حاول من خلال زيارته لطهران يوم الجمعه
الماضي الحفاظ على خيط من المناقشات مع
النظام الايراني لمحاوله استعاده السيطره
على انشطته بروسيل تقع امس ايضا الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس للمره الاولى وهي
علامه ايجابيه في حد ذاتها بحسب جروسي
الذي قال ان الوكاله تتخذ خطوه في الاتجاه
الصحيح وكاله الطاقه الذريه كشفت ان طهران
وافقت على عوده كاميرات المراقبه لبعض
المواقع النوويه والسماح للمفتشين بالوصول
الى اماكن رفضت طهران سابقا الوصول اليها
اضافه لزياده عمليات التفتيش بنسبه 50% في
منشاه فوردو لكن كما ذكرنا خرجت وكاله
الطاقه الذريه لتنفئه تماما موضوع
الكاميرات نتابع
[موسيقى]
اتفقنا على عدد من الاجراءات الملموسه
فخلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه كان هناك
انخفاض في بعض انشطه المراقبه لذا قررنا
مضاعفتها ووضع المزيد من الكاميرات وتعزيز
انظمه التدقيق عبر الانترنت واصلاح المعطل
منها المهم بالنسبه لنا هو ان ايران
ستلتزم بدرجه التخصيب المحدده لها في
منشاه فوردو وستحترم هذا الالتزام
بالفرنسيه اعتبرت ان توقف المفاوضات الدفع
الايرانيين لمواصله التجاوسات المحسوبه
وعلى الرغم من خطوره الموقف والانقطاع
الطويل في المراقبه الدوليه للانشطه
الايرانيه الا ان دولا كالولايات المتحده
لا يبدو انها تصبه اهتمامها في هذه
المرحله على الملف النووي الايراني واشارت
الصحيفه الفرنسيه في هذا الصدد الى تعليق
الرئيس جو بايدن خلال اجتماعا حزبي في
نوفمبر الماضي وقوله ان الاتفاق النووي
مات الا ان الولايات المتحده لن تعلن
وفاته بعد كما ذكرت الصحيفه بتصريح مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي بان المفاوضات مع
ايران ليست على جدول الاعمال اعمال
الاداره الامريكيه في الوقت الراهن
احد الاسباب التي دفعت الاداره الى العوده
للاتفاق النووي هو ان ايران كانت غير
مقيده في مواصله عمليات التخصيب وتقليل
وقت الاختراق الى اسابيع وربما شهور لكن
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران ليس في دائره
اولوياتنا في الوقت الراهن في ايران تواصل
تزويد روسيا بالمعدات والقدرات العسكريه
للاستمرار في قتل الاوكرانيين وتدعم
الارهابيين في الشرق الاوسط كما تستمر في
قمع التظاهرات في المدن الايرانيه لذلك
الامر ليس محطه اهتمام الاداره
اسرائيل على الجهه الاخرى تواصل دراسه ما
يمكنها لمواجهه البرنامج النووي لايران
لموند اشارت الى ان وزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه
ومستشاره الامن القومي الساحل
سيتوجهان الى واشنطن خلال الايام المقبله
لمناقشه خيارات الرد على ايران واليوم
انتقد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو حديثه
مدير عام الوكاله الذريه رفيع الجروسي
وقوله ان اي هجوم على المنشات الايرانيه
سيعتبر عملا خارجا عن القانون نتابع
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
اعلن في طهران ان الهجوم الاسرائيليه على
المنشات النوويه خارج عن القانون خارج عن
اي قانون بالنسبه لشخص مسؤول مثل جروسي هل
يجوز لايران التي تدعو بصراحه ووضوح الى
تدميرنا وان تحضر الادوات لقتلنا من
الواضح انه مسموح لنا بالدفاع عن انفسنا
لكن السؤال الى اي مدى وصل تطور البرنامج
النووي الايراني ومتى بامكانها صنع قنبله
او قنابل نوويه معهد العلوم والامن الدولي
الامريكي توقع في تقرير له انه يمكن
لايران انتاج ما يكفي من المواد المستخدمه
في صنع الاسلحه لصنع قنبله نوويه في غضون
12 يوما فقط وانتاج اربع قنابل اخرى في
غضونه شهر واحد تقرير المعهد حلل فيه
المعلومات التي قدمتها الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه واشاد الا انه يمكن للنظام
الايراني تخصيب ما يكفي من اليورانيوم
لتصنيع ما مجموعه سبعه اسلحه نوويه في
ثلاثه اشهر وتظهر النتائج ان ايران اقرب
من اي وقت مضى الى تجاوز العتبه النوويه
خاصه وان طهران قامت في الاشهر الاخيره
بتخصيب اليورانيوم الى مستويات اقل بقليل
من مستويات الاسلحه وهو ما اثار مخاوف من
ان ايران ربما تكون في طريقها نحو اختبار
سلاح نووي في اي لحظه لكن بالعوده الى
تقرير لمون فبحسب هذا التقرير ما يزال
امام ايران بين عام ونصف وعامين ونصف
للوصول الى سلاح نووي اخذا في الاعتبار
تخزين كميه مناسبه من اليورانيوم المخصب
عند 90% ثم صنع الراس النووي ودمجه في
صاروخ مناسب
[موسيقى]